as we see him warming up here
the numbers in the last two that 1-0
record 1-6-4 era 11 innings pitched and
that walk to strikeout ratio is
quite nice as you might say caitlyn with
a line driving a base hit to right field
so that was a fastball up and away and
matt chapman has a 12-game hitting
streak
listen a line drive right field base hit
gallows got a good arm
chapman is going to be held at third
and it's first and third one out moriano
at 260
13 homer's 27 rbis
toward right gallow hustling over and
he's not going to get it and it's going
to go by him and roll into the corner
chapman will score
olson to third he'll stop there ramon
laureano has an rbi double
and the a's lead one nothing early
bounces it toward third nice play by
bonnie as he throws to first
olson's able to come in and score so
these get their second run
the rangers get a nice defensive play by
andy's in
i think he thought about maybe throwing
home
decided against him
he had to go into that slide and i just
think
he probably felt like he didn't have the
opportunity to maybe put enough on him
colby allard checks to get his sign
infield plays to pull centerfield garcia
about two steps toward right center
and the 2-2 delivery to jet is swung on
line to right center for a base hit
and his three-nothing a's great job of
hitting
a line smash into right center by lowry
and the a's have an early three-nothing
lead over the rangers
what was that look like a wiffle ball
and they're wondering whether or not
that eli white's bat i think that's why
he's looking into the dugout right now
and
the oakland a's may want to take a look
at the replay now did it hit his
back first and then the bat they already
challenged
looks like it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
shoulder back whatever
pitch to calhoun is in the dirt it
bounds away from garcia
to the back stop white goes to second
he's taken off the third
here's the throw to third not in time
eli white dashes from first to third
as garcia couldn't find that ball
2-1 now to solace and a bouncer third
base it'll get a run home
chapman throws to first to get solac but
white scores rangers are on the board
no shift on for lowry 2-2 and that is
hit high in the air to center field
sending garcia back to the track he's at
the wall
it keeps on going and it gets out in
arlington
jed lowery with a sixth home run of the
year
a smash the center and it's 4-1
athletics
so a little bit of a mix-up on the
infield in fact it looked like avanias
may have
just maybe blocked the view of keiner
falafel
so we'll pass the ruling on when we get
it here's tony kemp his first
at bat hitting for cannon he's in the
game for cannon
he goes after the first pitch and skies
it
shallow right center gallow grabs it and
that will do it for the engine
payoff pitch that one came in and he
just does tap
it pass it will bury and throw not in
time
with wide speed you felt like there was
a good chance of him beating that out
and he does
an infield hit and the rangers have a
base runner in the forward
this one smashed up the middle just off
the end of lowry's glove into center
field
and that's a hit for calhoun two strikes
to solace the right hand batter and the
pitch he swings and misses
got him dotted in with a power sinker
and
solac has gone on strikes that's four
k's now
for bassett pass it though nearing 60
pitches
and he misses high ball four and they
are loaded
by evanya's one pitch
a little flare to center field bolt
coming in and he's gonna get there to
make the catch
so the rangers threaten do not score
they leave the bases loaded
we're on to the fifth inning four to one
eight
up the middle and that's going to get
through for a base hit so
miss garcia has his second hit this one
leading off the seventh inning
kim drives them toward right yellow
going back he's going to turn around
he's going to play it off the wall
garcia is headed for third and he will
stop there
tony camp with a double and the a's have
second and third and noble body out
having a single and a run score to fly
ball to the left and a pop out to second
right to the backstop as a weird karim
goes over toward the a's dugout
garcia comes in to score kemp goes to
third and it's five to one
another two two from spores
hit hard toward third now bonnie is
across the diamond pinder's retired the
a's get a run
on a wild pitch
[Applause]
lined out to right field though and
trevino is a boy
so fifth rangers hit of the game second
for jose
[Applause]
nice play flips to second for one on the
first double play
[Applause]
terrific play by alba andres just to
start the devil play
lowry had to turn it and the a's indeed
pick up the double play worth another
look
as we go to the eighth inning and we
will see now the
big league debut of joe barlow
right-handed pitcher certainly an
exciting moment for him to take a look
at the numbers
what he posted at triple a round rock
was throwing the ball very well in his
17 games at two and a half bra that whip
point seven six gold strike out the walk
ratio
it's one of eleven children
in his family growing up in riverton
utah and there's a swing in the midst he
strikes out lowry his first big league
strikeout that didn't take long
at all for barlow four pitches in he's
got himself a big league strikeout and
go ahead and get a stamp
on that baseball and it was on the
slider backdoor slider
so everybody's number jumped as you see
back-to-back strikeouts here
barlow's 1-0 pitch and that one's rolled
up the middle
kinder philippa takes care of it how
about a perfect
inning in relief for his big league
debut
hits his ball sharply pass first that's
a base hit into right field
calhoun smash that ball
[Applause]
catch at the wall spins around
fires it back in and what a play by tony
kemp
was able to concentrate hold on to the
ball
when it almost feels like tony kemp just
had his glove up
trying to track this thing down trying
to get it to fall
into his glove stick it up there and
pray
that's not it tony kemp was tracking
that baseball not easily done
that's a heck of a play for tony kim so
two outs
trevino to left and that should do it
and that will do it
so the a's get a win today and as we
said at the open of our show
they needed a win and they get it they
get a split in the four game
series with the texas rangers
so these will head back home get set for
the giants